احتجاجا على استمرار الهجمات الكيماويه
على المدارس في جميع انحاء ايران دعت
مجموعه شبابيه في ايران تطلق على نفسها
شباب احياء طهران الى المشاركه في تظاهره
غدا الثلاثاء امام مبنى البرلمان الايراني
ودوائر التعليم والتربيه في العاصمه
مشددين على ان هذه الممارسات هي لشد
الانتباه عن الاحتجاجات كما دعت نقابات
المعلمين وطلاب الجامعات الى تجمع احتجاجي
على مستوى البلاد ايضا غدا الثلاثاء
للمطالبه بوضع حد للقمع البيولوجي وتهديد
حياه المواطنين المجلس التنسيقي لنقابات
المعلمين طالب ايضا بالسماح لوفد من
النشاطاء المدنيين والنقابيين والسياسيين
المستقلين الى جانب مجموعه من الاطباء
ونشطاء حقوق الانسان بدراسه موضوع التصميم
داخل المدارس والتحقيق فيه وشدد المجلس
التنسيقي لنقابات المعلمين في بيانه على
ان حجم المدارس التي تعرضت للهجوم والعدد
الكبير من التلاميذ المصابين يدل على ان
مشروع الاعمال التعسفيه لمنتسب النظام
المتشددين محل شك كبير وفي نفس السياق
ابدى العديد من المنظمات النقابيه دعمها
لدعوه المجلس التنسيقي لنقابات المعلمين
حتى الوصول الى بيئه تعليميه امنه
[موسيقى]